هذا العام سبق عيد الام شهر رمضان بيومين
فرصه ثانويه لشراء الهدايا للامهات فكيف
تاثرت بدخول رمضان بعض الابناء يحاولون
شراء هديه تجمع المناسبتين ولهذا يلجاون
للاماكن التي تبيع منتجات يدويه الصنع انا
جايه انا ومامتي علشان لو حاجه هي بتحب
الحاجات اللي والهند والحاجات دي لو
عجبتها هجيب لها
بعض منتجي السلع اليدوي يستعدوا من خلال
تصميمات ذات علاقه بالمناسبتين معا وفي
هذه الحاله وجدنا الكثير من مندمج رمضان
في عيد الام اللي بيدور على عيد الام
موجوده بيدور على رمضان موجود في حاجات
عاملاها ميكس ما بين الاتنين يعني زي مثلا
كاتبه عليها رمضان احلى مع جدتي رمضان
احلى مع امي فتبقى هديه الاثنين مع بعض
عيد الام ورمضان كل فتره من دول بيبقى لها
سي معين في البيت فمثلا رمضان كلنا بنجهز
ديكورات رمضان والبيت كله بيقلب ديكورات
رمضان ونشيل الديكورات العاديه في كريسماس
برضه البيت كله بيقلب وكريسماس فيعني
اعتقد ان هي السيزون دي بتبقى حلوه يعني
وسواء تزامن عيد الام مع رمضان ام لا
فدائما ما تستعد متاجر وبيع الزهور كل عام
بكميات كبيره من السلعه الاكثر مبيعا في
هذه المناسبه
تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره